si leur a sûrement été national national
était au pouvoir il ay et c'est déjà le
cas aujourd'hui on a un chômage de masse
on a des problèmes sécuritaires on a des
valeurs identitaires on a des problèmes
de désindustrialisation triste locales
ne décrivait pas le décrivait pas le
scénario de la france gouvernée par leur
assure leur nationale alors que c'est
précisément le scénario non que vous
vivez aujourd'hui on paie pour le fun
mobilité vous ne fondez pas un parti où
toutes ces idées sont défendus à
l'exception de l'obsession des étrangers
d'immigration à ce que l'immigration
parce que l'émigration est un sujet
attendait
l'immigration est aussi un sujet quand
j'entendais souvent j'entends dire quand
j'entends dire qu'il n'ya aucun lien
entre l'immigration et l'insécurité je
suis désolé vous aider millions
téléspectateurs ce soir qui sont mort de
rire
le l'audience le dernier rosa et de
l'autre on attendait le thé le thé le
type le lui attendait le tester des
idées le terrorisme le terroriste
pakistanais qui a poignardé des gens de
fond charlie hebdo siné parce qu'il ait
dahmane raser les mecs qui ont rafalé
les gens au bataclan
c'était pas des français etc etc oui
d'accord pour arrêter de dire qu' à
aucun lien ça n'est pas assez ambitieux
là-dessus qu'il faut juste de romandie
un monsieur qui veut réformer le
pakistan deux pakistanais le pakistanais
dont jamais ça parle a été poursuivi par
un algérien en situation irrégulière
bien s'ils avaient trente trois ans qui
s'appelait ue ces examens dans le
bâtiment et bien jamie ciat et sirem
dépasser le seul lien armée si je dis
que vous pouvez pas nier qu'il y a un
lien social
ce que je ne nie pas c'est qu'il y à des
délinquants aux scènes de l'immigration
comme il y en a au sein de la nation
c'est pas les mêmes tons tortionnaires
de la même veine on s'est parlé de
contention des liens qu'il faut
combattre pas l'immigré exact que je ne
renie pas c'est qu'on a mis sa main mise
mais radicale qui est un dévoiement de
l'islam
mais si l'islamisme radical combat c'est
pas les musulmans et l'islam radical qui
reconnaît comme valence
public donc aussi s'est-il mec à muriel
non à sylvain et à d'autres que en
stoppant l'immigration on résoudra les
problèmes d'abord lui dire non si lever
une partie réguler ou de réguler les
flux migratoires c'est nécessaire et
n'est pas fait mais dire stop à
l'immigration
non tu peux pas l'empêcher il faut
sauter c'est une ineptie lutte et
qu'encore une fois contre l'extrémisme
religieux qui est un dévoiement de la
religion quelqu'un doit absolument
indispensable mais c'est indispensable
mais il va il faut le faire avec les
musulmans pas contre les musulmans moi
je compare ce que les premières victimes
de ces amalgames ce sont les musulmans